what are the chances you, being you.
lets start with your birthday. Odds are that you were born in August, September, or July, the most popular months for birthdays.
while chances are slimmest that you were born in February or April.
and what about the day of the week your were born?
its most likely you were born on a Tuesday, Wednesday, or Thursday.
Turns out most babies take the weekends off.
and odds are greatest that you came into the world all by yourself.
there's only a three percent chance of you being a twin. And a very tiny chance of you being a triplet or a quadruplet.
what about your name?
Even if you have a relatively popular name, like David or Rachel, Joe or Lauren, theres still a really slim chance that you'd wind up with that name.
if your guy that chances are greatest that your 5'10". And if your girl you most likely 5' 4".
And if we were to reverse those heights, theres than a 3 percent chance of a guy being 5'4" and a girl being 5'10".
In fact theres less than a 1% for a girl to be 5'11" or any height above.
And less than a 5% chance for a guy to be any height above 6'1".
I'll if you were born in the US
theres about a 13 percent chance you're born in California
and a 10 percent chance you're born in Texas.
theres a %46 chance you were born in Illinois, Florida, or New York.
And less than a %3 chance you were born anywhere else.
but taking into consideration the entire world
there's less than one percent chance that you were even born in the US.
So really, no matter where you're from, or how tall you are, or what your name is, One thing is clear...
You, are incredibly rare.